[Music]
the entire time I knew him he only ever
had one call
[Music]
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
danos
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming to us
we have a dance once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan dears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good
Wow
[Music]
the end is near
none done
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
as all things should be
I hope they remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man so this is it it's always
leave news
ready let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
before creation itself there were
sixteen gelareh teams forged into
Infinity stones
this is our first day here we aren't
finding wood in Atlanta and it's it's
actually pretty unbelievable day one of
what promises to be a year of fun-filled
lensing I remember actually going to see
the first Avengers with one of my best
mates from home and I'd never have
dreamed that I'd ever be in one of these
movies let alone playing spider-man I
feel like I'm on top of the world
because this is just mind-blowing
what we always try to do at marvel
studios is we're building the cinematic
universe is look at the big picture how
can things relate across movies and
across years Avengers infinity war is
the culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe as started in May of
2008 with a release of Iron Man 1 and it
really is an unprecedented culmination
of a series of films interlinked
together which it's time had never been
done before and for us the important
thing is making it all come together we
know they're gonna face
Thanos we've been setting that up since
Avengers 1 how do you do that in a way
that is unexpected that pits the
Avengers against somebody who's more
powerful than anyone they face and yet
make them completely unprepared to face
him well tear them apart which is why we
did Civil War before infinity war as we
were conceiving and executing Civil War
the end of that movie was very much a
setup for what these movies would be we
always had that sense of that
tony is not talking to Steve the
Avengers are basically a name with
nobody in it the world is vulnerable
Tony senses his greater threats
approaching and so he is doing
everything in his power to keep the
earth safe
thanos shows us why he's the biggest the
best the baddest villain that we've ever
had and the most frightening villain
that the Avengers have ever facing the
most exciting part is the incredible
roster of well developed characters and
it's going to create a really
combustible exciting massive scale
adventure you know that we're on to
something within the studio when we hit
upon an idea or we see a piece of
concept art and all of us in the room go
this is cool and an Avengers infinity
war the Avengers will meet the guardians
of the galaxy
because of what Marvel is because of
what they have done over the last ten
years
these next two Avengers films will be an
event like no one has ever seen on film
before
[Music]
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right there to fail all the same
read it
run from it Dustin still arrived
evacuate the city
engage your defenses
and get this manna sheet
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers
imbalance in the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
[Music]
the hell are you guys
[Music]
[Music]